so you said these books are difficult
maybe you can comment on which aspect is
difficult
is it just the technical nature is that
the length is it the depth of the ideas
or how long it takes to integrate them
and more sort of importantly is there
recommendation advice you can give on
how to
integrate these ideas how to read
how to learn in the spaces there from
your own life
like how do you enjoy taking in ideas
and this could be for these books but
also
uh in the bitcoin world and reading a
bunch of different ideas
written by others just integrating stuff
even watching podcasts and all those
kinds of things yeah i
i'm a reader i love to read um
one of the most useful things i've ever
done was take a speed reading course
i actually think there's a version of
this available on tim ferriss's website
it's like a 30 minute speed reading
course
it's all about eye movement instead of
moving your eye continuously
line over line it's more about jumping
in your brain you can train your brain
to just
absorb words in their totality versus
kind of reading word by word
and also not i've i've haven't fully
taken that journey actually but
i remember taking a few steps on that
journey
realizing that i'm speaking inside my
head
yeah i'm saying the words inside my head
and that's actually getting in the way
that's right
so there's a lot of little hacks like
that i maybe lazily i'll have to now
that you mentioned i'll have to revisit
this
yeah but i have convinced myself that
i don't need to read faster because
that's not ultimately the bottleneck the
bottleneck isn't
me thinking about stuff in fact i like
reading really slowly
or so i convince myself because i
ultimately it's not about
gaining more information it's about time
spent thinking deeply yes um but
maybe that's just me being very lazy
because yes it's true it's important to
think deeply but maybe i could speed up
the
the consumption of information but it's
fine it's i i like to be dynamic
actually so
um usually speed reading initially and
that
diffused that internal dialogue for me
because when i was reading one word at a
time i was having that too you almost
get a feedback in your own head
you're reading the word out loud right
flouting your thoughts yeah if you're
speed reading you can't do that
you just you're taking in groups of
words at a time so you can't
you know internally verbalize it i guess
and then i also am really big on
annotating underlining writing in the
margins
i prefer a physical book but i also read
the kindle a lot because it's just so
convenient you know
anywhere you're waiting in line or every
night before bed i'm reading my kindle
and i also advocate rereading a lot so
if you found
something that you know struck you at a
deep level
you found particularly fascinating like
you have to listen to that that's your
i don't know your mind your spirit
signal that that is something meaningful
to you
and you should you know to your point
reread it sit with it for a long time
write about it
and that that becomes the ultimate
triumvirate of synthesizing an idea
actually if you can read about it
and then write about it and then go and
talk about it
you get this crystallization of
understanding that's just not possible
doing any one of the three or any two of
the three
um so i definitely highly recommend
people to do that and in terms of
how are those books difficult i mean in
every way they're all long books
uh in terms of density
i would say lila is the less the least
dense
maybe maps of meaning
i don't know but maps of meaning and
human action are both extremely dense
but they're just you i had to read those
books very slow
you just have to take your time with
them um to give you an idea with jordan
peterson he's said this a lot with maps
of meaning
he spent three hours a day writing for
15 years
to write that book it's probably i think
it's a 600 page book
he said he estimates he rewrote every
sentence in the book 50 times 5-0
to try and get it you know just
perfected and
when you read these sentences you can
tell
that he rewrote it 50 times i've uh i've
used actually enki for space repetition
um it's like a piece of it's an app i'm
not sure if you're familiar with it but
it allows you to load in
facts or terms or entire paragraphs
and then it brings them
you review them every day and then it
brings them up
less and less often over time as you
show yourself being able to remember
the thing that uh you wanted to memorize
and oftentimes what i'm reading what i
want to memorize is the key idea
but also like i use it for i'm terrible
with names so i'm
starting to use it for names too of
names of people names of
like people that i want to remember yeah
and also throughout history and also my
personal life but also events
you know dates to me are usually not
important but sometimes dates are really
important
and so it's really useful i recommend
highly naval i think
mentioned a piece of software called
read wise or something like that that
i hope i'm saying that correctly it's
something like that
and what it does is it goes to your
highlights from your
kindle or the various places where you
highlight stuff that
integrates with uh goodreads
and it does the same kind of space
repetition but for things you've
highlighted
so cool it's it sends an email every day
it's it's been really i recommend it
highly because it
it sensed like to me an email form
a selection of the things i've
highlighted in previous things i've read
and it's like this weird like shock
shock to your memory that sprinkles like
i'll have a
probably way too much orwell in there
and it just kind of like
it brings you back and these ideas are
because
what you realize depending on how you
highlight
but at least for me and i think it's
probably true for a lot of people the
things you've highlighted
had at that moment and like an emotional
impact on you
yeah and so like these things are just
like hitting you hard again
it's like whoa uh it might not be
meaningful to anyone else except you and
it it's uh
it's something i recommend you never
know with these like hacks or tools and
so on
like what's actually bs and what what is
amazing and that one is
kind of amazing so at least for me it
work it works for me and naval i think
i think read wise you so read-wise yeah
or something
close to that yeah it could be read
something else like
read wealth or something the one other
thing i
really like and this is more of a new
one is i used to always listen to
music at the gym but now i've just
because i'm so backlogged on
podcast right they're just there's so
many
i exclusively listen to podcasts when
i'm walking or when i'm at the gym
anytime i'm doing something that i can't
you know read basically and
i think there's something really special
about exercise and ideation
i mean i i don't know if this happens to
everyone but my creative juices just go
ballistic
when i'm at the gym like i hit a certain
point of i guess heart rate and you're
sweating enough that
the ideas just start to flow yeah so i'm
basically
at the gym now listening to podcasts
exercising
as fast as i can to try to get to that
state of um
you know where you're just straining
your strenuous exercise i guess you
would say
and then i'm end up typing notes into my
phone as fast as i can with all these
ideas that are flowing
so i've i've created a lot of good
writing out of that
yeah it's kind of work so i i do running
uh quite a bit so running outside and uh
i'll listen
i've been okay i told myself this has
been going on for about a year
uh is i only listen
like this the stuff that's either world
war ii or world war one related so
hitler stalin
like like difficult historical stuff
um and also listen to brown noise
so those are the two modes so brown
noise helps me
it's like white noise but like deeper i
guess it helps me
remove the world and at the gym there's
a lot of distractions when you're
running there's a lot of distractions it
helps me remove the world so
one i'll be listening to difficult
historical ideas
and then when my mind is all of a sudden
starting to generate ideas
i'll listen to brown noise and i'll then
force myself to think
it's kind of it's meditative in a sense
and your mind wants to be lazy you want
to
you it's hard man like running and
thinking
in the sense that some of the ideas that
come into your head are pretty heavy
it's about your own life it's all your
own demons come in there
but also just difficult ideas that
require you thinking through and
persevering through that like not
letting yourself get lazy and like
thinking through it
has has been really for me rewarding in
the same way that you're you're saying
it is for you it's true that like
podcasts
and music like um shallow like funny
podcasts
or music have been a kind of filler
distraction
but informational podcasts like podcasts
that have some
depth of ideas or audio books have been
truly rewarding i try to listen now less
and less to podcasts that are just fun
because i feel like i enjoy it too much
and i don't allow my mind to get bored
and to think through stuff to uh to
explore ideas
it's so easy to fill the the space
that uh usually would be thought filled
with thought
and instead fill it with fun podcasts
like
there's a bunch of comedy podcasts i
really enjoy so
there's value to that of course but you
have to realize it's entertainment it's
not
it's it's not um you don't get much
value except entertainment
right right and there's utility to the
boredom too i think
to give your mind the space i guess your
subconscious
may be the space to chew on some of
these problems right where you've
imbibed so much knowledge
you know you've highlighted and thought
about something but then you need to
stop thinking about it for a while and
let it marinate in the subconscious
and then you know these flashes of
insight that people have described
sometimes i get them in the middle of
the night like i just wake up from a
dream and have them and i got to write
it down or sometimes just
in nature taking a walk but i think
that's very important too
we can't just brute force our way into
understanding
you know there's this interplay between
kind of the brute force reading intake
and then just
relaxing meditating sleeping being bored
uh letting your subconscious do the
heavy lifting and there's uh like you
should be aware of
the fact that there's a war for your
attention going on so there's a lot of
there's been better and better and
better mechanisms that are designed to
steal your attention
so i kind of see it as a war zone
between my
right for boredom
and the internet wanting your attention
in fact um
clubhouse as an app has been
i'm probably not going to use clubhouse
much anymore it's
there's some aspect of my own inner
loneliness and whatever
it is that pulled me into clubhouse a
little bit too much
to where where it robbed me from that
lonely time
alone where i sit and listen to bruce
springsteen and think about life
so i want to that's way more important
this way well yeah at least
you know it's all in balance because
there is uh a clubhouse like a lot of
these social networks when you use right
can be a way to discover new ideas new
people
but the boredom and just being alone
with your thoughts is uh
priceless absolutely and you got to know
yourself right like
it took me a long time to realize i need
solitude yeah
like just how i'm wired how i'm built i
need like an hour a day
solitude so you gotta listen to that
part of yourself you might be
compromising something like that where
you feel like you always need to be with
your girlfriend or whatever it may be
but
i would suggest listening to that voice
yeah i tried to
i tried to remember things that made me
feel good over time
like long term had positive impact and
long term had negative impact and do
more of the former and less of the
latter yeah
we don't often think like that you know
we talked offline about like carnivore
diets for example
i try to remember that carbs don't make
me feel good
yeah in the moment it's hard to remember
that
but you have to remember that that
that's the case in
in the same way exercise
it's hard to remember that exercise
makes me feel good
uh like especially when it's time to go
to the gym especially when it's time to
go to the gym but you should remember
that because
the kind of person you are without
exercise for me
yet just like he's beautifully said that
you have to know yourself the kind of
person i
am without exercise is a less
good person a person a person i'm less
proud of yeah
the food thing is so hard by the way i
still
you know i i can't tell you how many
times i've learned the lesson like don't
eat that
but then you know you go a few weeks of
not eating whatever that is
and you're feeling good and then you're
you're i don't know something creeps up
inside you like ah you could just have
one or you just do this but for me it's
sugar like sugar
just makes me feel terrible but i always
not always but
if it's been a long time i start to make
that exception in my mind like oh you
can have a little bit yeah
and then i eat it and i feel terrible so
i don't know how many times i've done
that dance but
it's not cool well it depends on how
painful it is and then you learn the
lesson i've
haven't i actually embraced the fact
that i'll never learn the lesson with
vodka
every time i drink especially with
russians
is like i quit drinking every time and
then
i forget there's like a slow drop off
it'll be like a two weeks and then
nasdar very good
so it never makes you feel good
it never results in anything good um
except the beautiful social
chaos yeah which is ultimately somehow
there's value to chaos too you know
there's value to that whatever the hell
stupid stuff you do when you get
trashed the over-the-top emotion of
love usually or whatever yeah
camaraderie there's value to that too
like as i get older i realize
because uh the world
sometimes especially when you get older
and the world wants you to be an adult
in order to maintain the youthful spirit
you have to use all the tools you can
alcohol is one of them right to do all
the stupid [ __ ] you can
even if you're like getting older to
lower the inhibitions and
always against that taste of uncertainty
that is the sweetness of life right to
be able to go out
and be a fliner at a party and not
really know what you're gonna do
and it's we we have this draw to the
wild side of life
uh as much as we try and build up order
around ourselves i think there's always
going to be an appetite for that
um i've always most of my life i've
always been a social drinker
but actually gave up alcohol a year ago
and um
i would add that to the the idea
uh the repertoire for dealing with
bigger ideas
because alcohol is fun to me you know
good times it can be analgesic it can do
all it can give you all these benefits
if you use
uh the right amounts but i got to the
point personally where i was trying to
wrestle with these ideas that are just
so much bigger than me that i and i have
this
backlog of books that was growing faster
than i could read them
did i just reach the point where i
decided um
i wanted to start making sacrifices
toward attaining that
and alcohol was just an easy one you
know it's you spend
even if you just drink socially on the
weekends you're probably spending
five to ten hours drinking and then
maybe another what
five to ten hours recovering perhaps on
the day after
um so it was a
difficult transition initially but once
you get through
a couple of months i feel amazing
without it i sleep better than ever
my workouts are better than ever i'm
sharper than ever i'm more lucid
so i'm not trying to be a proponent for
like not drinking but i just want to see
your proponent for sacrifice
i am a big component of sacrifice yes
you